[Music]
the world is full of odd delightful and
mysterious objects but some of them are
harder to come by than others thankfully
there are people who have dedicated
their lives to collecting well just
about everything in my work I really
tried to reproduce smell scenarios for
different purposes be it three P the
neighborhood in the city I've done
cousin so smell all over the world could
we on behalf of a small molecule find
out something about history but we
otherwise wouldn't know this is sisal
Tallis she has many things an artist a
scientist but more importantly a smell
expert she however prefers another title
i'm call myself a professional
in-betweener
which means what exactly there's a whole
world to smell and the whole word to
indicate how to smell so you cannot just
limit yourself to one discipline right
the point is she has dedicated her life
to the sense of smell what it means but
how it can be used to better understand
the world and each other pretty early in
my life I started ask questions why are
we only understanding the world on
behalf of how the world look like what
if we started using other senses more
appropriate for the same purpose why
we're starting to discover the same
world I've been looking at for several
years using the nose for the purpose so
how exactly did you go about recording
and then reproducing these smells I will
walk around identify smells with my own
nose
I have small devices that enable me to
collect the smell Malik is emitting from
the source with the result I go to my
lab and then the data I get is then the
starting point of reproduction of the
actual smell I have a lab consisting of
up to four thousand chemical compounds
and with those ingredients as with those
compounds
I literally reproduce invisible reality
that surround you full-time all the time
name a city a neighborhood within a
neighborhood a historical building or
even an era in time and most likely
sizzle has reproduced that smell along
with thousands of other cents here in
her lab with the hopes of using the
findings for a bigger purpose the
purpose can be tolerance education
navigation to memorize the list is
endless is more interesting if you
really start to understand the smells
and see how you can use that information
for a purpose beyond the smell itself it
can be beetles that come off a cactus it
can be the dried urine of a cow little
insects that grow on an oak tree a chunk
of lead that's soaked in vinegar it's
truly amazing
[Music]
we're in Harvard University outside the
shorts pigment collection pigment is a
very small particle of colored material
that is mixed in with a binding medium
the pigment gives paint its color the
fourth pigment collection has been
brought together over several decades we
have around 2,500 pigments we have a lot
of very unusual and very rare colors so
this is I think one of the more
unusually named pigments it's called
Dragon's Blood it doesn't come from
dragons it comes from rattan palms and
it gives a very bright red pigment the
unusual aspect of mummy has to do with
its source rather than the color itself
and that comes from Egyptian mummies and
it's the resin that's applied to the
outside of the bandages I think the
rarest color that we have is actually a
an entire ball of Indian yellow and this
is a pigment that is made from the dried
urine of cows that are fed only on mango
leaves if you're looking at a work of
art and you want to understand what is
original and what's a restoration you
will take a tiny sample of pigment and
analyze it a lot of the pigments are
actually toxic so you don't want to
handle the pigments and then go out to
lunch
there's a green called emerald green
that has an arsenic Center to it we can
use them for telling if something is
real or not people will say this is by a
certain artist and we can look at the
materials that are used and decide if
those materials were available during
that artists lifetime
if not then we have to look at who might
have painted that picture I can't pick a
personal favorite there it's like asking
to pick a favorite child no the other
2,400 would feel left out
[Music]
the Sonia's National Museum of Natural
History has over 144 million objects
like this novel tub my name is Kirk
Johnson I'm in charge of all of them 99
percent of the collections are behind
the scenes these are the people that
work with them this is Carla dove the
division of birds here in the division
of birds we have somewhere around six
hundred and twenty thousand museum
specimens and that represents about
eighty-five percent of the diversity of
birds in the world you look at these
specimens and you realize that this is
where the science is really gonna start
we're using our collections to identify
birds that collide with airplanes and
help us improve aviation safety dr. Bob
Robbins curator of butterflies and moths
I have been professionally employed as
an lepidopterist want some butterflies
for about 35 years this is the essence
of my being is to know everything about
butterflies there's a whole world out
there that unless you look very closely
you don't see and it's an interesting
world it's a fascinating world and it is
full of practical value for human beings
strong curator of mollusks what I love
about this collection is its breadth we
estimate that we may have as many as 20
million specimens we are preserving a
record of past life on this planet of
present life on this planet and
preserving that for the future
I take that responsibility very
seriously and providing access and
caring for the specimens for posterity
dr. Jeff post curator the National gem
and mineral collection minerals in this
collection go from something that formed
maybe in the last few tens of years to
others that form more than three billion
years ago we know right now there's more
than 5,000 minerals that make up the
earth and in our collection we probably
have more than half of those each one's
a little piece of the puzzle and you try
to put all these things together and
hopefully eventually understand the big
picture of how the earth works employed
chocolate collection manager for
entomology we have just a little over 35
million specimens in the collection 1/3
of all insect life on earth is
represented by at least one specimen our
collection
when you look at a collection the size
of ours you're starting to get to a
point where you can ask really big
questions the questions related to
global climate change habitat
destruction and you can only answer
those big questions with you have a lot
of specimens collected over a long
period of time a lot of different
species to understand the earth and
living things of the earth
you need to collect those things and
preserve them and study them and that
helps you when you need food or when you
have a disease all that stuff arcs back
the fact that we have samples of the
whole planet here and that's how we
understand the planet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the Harvard brain Bank is one of the
largest brain banks in the country
at the moment we house approximately
5000 brain specimens
[Music]
my name is Sabina Bavetta I am the
scientific director of the Harvard brain
tissue Resource Center which we
affectionately call Harvard brain Bank
our mission is to collect brain
specimens store them characterize them
and then redistribute them out to
investigators across the world the do
research on the human brain and in
particular on large number of
neurological and psychiatric brain
disorders such as schizophrenia bipolar
disorder Parkinson Huntington and many
others depend on canaveral sleeps we
have two sets of people that are gone
called 24/7 we have a very limited time
window from when the person passes away
to the time we need to be done with this
whole processing so this is gonna be
your first train late at night right we
have to do it in less than 24 hours our
courier will bring it from training
hospital to the brain Bank so just put
it out here so we're gonna take
ourselves it will be a dissection is
ready to dissect a brain
that involves so separating the two
hemispheres one of the two hemispheres
is put in a solution that preserves it
the other hemisphere will be dissected
in thick sections and those will be
frozen we are not even close to
understand a lot of what we take for
granted our thoughts were instants of
our feelings our emotions there are a
lot of questions we still don't know and
a lot of our brain functions still will
probably be studied for a long time to
come a brain donation is in a very
concrete way a gift of knowledge and it
cannot be done without the help of
families and people willing to donate
their brain
[Music]
in spring-green Wisconsin there is a
house on a rock but it is so much more
than that inside it is home to many
bizarre and incredible collections
there's a room of self playing
instruments an infinity room a giant
squid attacking a whale and some
nightmare inducing dolls it seems like a
really strange Museum and that's because
no it appears to be Museum because it is
housing antiques it's housing all kinds
of memorabilia and things from a
different era it's more of a place to
just enjoy so what is house on the rock
the house on the rock to me is a magical
complex it's an all-around sensory
explosion it was made by Alex Jordan who
was an architect not at all not at all
he is not a trained man he's just a man
of great vision maybe not an architect
but an evident hoarder
Alex Jordan with the help of his friends
built the house on the rock in the 40's
and opened it to the public in the 60s
his collections of antiques and junk new
items and old real and quite obviously
fake
have no central theme or apparent reason
for being there and maybe that's part of
its charm there are some pretty
incredible things including a huge
unraidable carousel 269 different
animals not one of them is a horse
really yes the horses adorn the walls of
course they do you know every time you
turn the corner here it's a different
thing and it's a different Wow and you
don't know what to expect
one man's trash is another man's
roadside tourist attraction
[Music]
you